you've become the intellectual Nick
ocado avocado you are obese obese with
interesting ideas so we're going to go
through as many as we can get through
today my first one one of my favorites
idiocy saturation online people who
don't think before they post are able to
post more often than people who do as a
result the average social media post is
stupider than the average social media
user worth remembering whenever Twitter
dumbassery drives you to despair
yeah so by Twitter domassery what I mean
is if you just go onto Twitter and
unfiltered and you're not sort of you
don't have a curated feed
and you just look at the posts it makes
you want to blow your brains out just
because there's just so much garbage
it's just an avalanche of garbage
um and it kind of like when I first went
on to Twitter I got a really low opinion
of humanity because I was fooled into
believing that this was reflective of
what humans actually think
um but it actually took me a bit of time
to realize that the stuff that you see
on social media is overwhelmingly cons
it consists of stuff that people have
posted hastily without thought
because the people who really think
about what they're posting they take a
lot longer to post and so naturally it's
going to be filled with stuff like
um oh I'm tired LOL you know I'm gonna
go to bed and I'll and stuff like
meaningless nonsense like that is going
to be the stuff that makes the majority
of social media posts and I think this
is why it's so important to curate your
feed
um because I always say that
a social media feed is the worst
possible source of information you can
have but a well-curated social media
feed is amongst the very best sources of
information you can have it makes such a
difference it's the difference between
hell and heaven and um
a large part of that really consists of
filtering out people who don't think
before they post people who just give in
to their worst impulses and just follow
their whims rather than actually
following their logic and their
rationality what was that Insight you
had around how
famous people will tweet some half-baked
idea whilst they're sat on the toilet
that will then be studied by the entire
world for the next three weeks
yeah I mean um I mean this was kind of
like a guess but I think that this is
true I suspect it's true I think we kind
of what's happened is that people that
have a tendency to over interpret
information online so they'll read into
information a lot more than was intended
and I mean I call this the
politicization of Babel basically I
think that's what it what it actually is
is a lot of people don't look because
they don't think before they post
they're just making a comment about
something that just off the top of their
head it's just something that's come
very
sort of you know quickly to their mind
and it's something that they just vomit
out they don't really think about it and
then what happens is you get people on
the other side of the world who will see
that and they will assume that this is a
hill that the person's willing to die on
something that they've spent their
entire life thinking about and they will
scrutinize it and dissect it and
evaluate it and write essays on it and
I've seen this happen a lot you know
with I mean nowadays you get whole
articles whole news articles written
about one tweak you know some if some
famous person like Elon Musk if he just
just you know farts out a tweet uh then
you'll get like a BBC journalist who
will basically
just lock onto that tweet and then
they'll just write a whole piece about
it and they'll just completely
scrutinize it as though they could sort
of
give a psychological profile based on
this one tweet you know and I think
that's very dangerous because most
people don't think very much before they
tweet it's just a whim it's like when
you go and meet somebody and you have a
cocktail party and then they just start
just talking they're not they're not
really thinking they're just trying to
make conversation
um so they'll just say stuff that they
don't even mean half the time and I
think this is something that people need
to realize is that when people say
things it doesn't necessarily mean that
they mean what they're saying sometimes
people are just they're just sort of
experimenting you know they're just kind
of throwing out ideas out there just to
see what people think of it and to be
honest I do that as well I don't
actually uh firmly believe a lot of the
stuff that I tweet out I just tweet it
out just to see how people react and you
know then I can maybe sort of calibrate
what I'm thinking based on that
um so yeah we shouldn't take what people
tweet out or what they post seriously
online most of the time because they
might feel differently five minutes
after in fact I do that all the time you
know something and then I'll just five
minutes after I've tweeted it I've got a
completely different opinion and I'm
like actually what I just tweeted was a
load of [__] you know and um yeah so I
think people need to to bear that in
mind Scott Adams actually had a really
good uh idea where he he calls it the
48-hour rule where he says that we
should never judge what a person has
posted until 48 hours have passed and
we've given that person a chance to
retract what they've said
obviously
this is not feasible it's not something
that you could actually do in real life
because you know you can't wait 48 hours
after every opinion but I like the idea
behind it because I think a lot of what
people say
is essentially it's kind of like just a
Untamed frison of
some Sensations they've had in them in
their mind you know something that's
just kind of triggered them to just say
something
um and they haven't really so they
haven't domesticated it they haven't
really you know tamed it so it's just a
wild idea that's just kind of unwrapping
in their head and they've just decided
to just you know let it out of the cage
the uh this is this is facilitated by
the frictionlessness of social media you
know previously if you wanted to use the
Gutenberg printing press to actually get
something down onto paper the you would
make sure that you'd spent some time
thinking about what you were going to
get this one very very small slot that
you had to be able to produce your
incredibly important pamphlet or
whatever you're talking about but you're
right the the frictionlessness allows
brain to mouth or brain to fingertips to
be instantaneous this is something that
I realized around the Jordan Peterson uh
Sports Illustrated girl furore was it
last year I think and yeah I love Jordan
he's been a massive influence on me and
he's very very kind to me but things
like that
people tried to dissect exactly what was
going on in the inner recesses of
Jordan's mind when he said sorry not
beautiful and no amount of totalitarian
overreach will convince me otherwise
everything about that tweet and almost
everything really that the older guys on
Twitter are putting out can be
understood if you remember that they're
Boomers
all that you need to do is just remember
the fact that they're about right filter
it through this isn't somebody who has a
a particularly additionally
sophisticated Twitter
habit or or process that they go through
before they construct a tweet you know
our friends some of our friends who are
way way less famous George Mack yourself
you know
these guys craft tweets over over weeks
takes weeks and weeks to come up with
these huge mega threads and George will
show me his notes and he's building him
up over time and all this sort of stuff
I guarantee that Jordan took less than
three minutes probably to type that
tweet out and yet it's then going to be
indicative of his pathologization let's
get the psychiatrists in to work out oh
is this something to do with his
unrequited jungian archetype from the
like no no no no like it's just he saw
an image of it he saw an image of a girl
on Sports Illustrated that he didn't
like and he had a crack and maybe you
know maybe he'd been gassy that day yeah
maybe exactly maybe he'd had a [__]
night's sleep because of Builders next
door like yeah the frictionlessness
facilitates this and I think I think
it's the tweets that people don't think
about very much that tend to be the ones
that people talk about most oh
absolutely yeah because because if it's
reasonable if you've actually spent a
long time thinking about it then it's
going to be reasonable and if it's
reasonable it's not gonna outrage people
it's not gonna uh make people sort of
it's not going to stir up emotions in
people because it's going to be the
antithesis of that it's going to be
something calm measured reasonable but
if you are just firing off what's the
first thought that instantly comes into
your head then it's by definition not
going to be reasonable it's going to be
something that's impulsive and that's
going to make other people impulsive and
they're going to react to it in that
same kind of language as it were the
language of sort of the animal language
of of human nature rather than the
language of reason and so I think that's
one of the dangerous things about social
media is that it tends to favor ideas
that people don't think very much about
people that just sort of
are a product of human whim rather than
human reason there's a Associated idea
you had Shaker's law those who announced
their departure from an online
discussion almost never actually leave
yeah I mean I I've got no way of knowing
whether this is true as a kind of
general rule of law but I think
um it's
it's probably it's something I suspect
is probably true because I personally
haven't really sort of engaged in in
arguments with people very much recently
um but when I used to I used to spend a
lot of time on on Twitter just arguing
with people and I'd often get people who
would just say oh I've had enough of
this you know this this I'm it's not
worth my time you know and all this
stuff and then I would say something
that would just bait them out again and
then they'd come back and they'd be like
so you know this happened so many times
that I just thought yeah this has got to
be real it needs to be a name
yeah yeah absolutely and it does happen
on on websites where it's where blocking
is less of a thing so websites like
Reddit you can block on Reddit but it's
a lot more torturous a lot more harder
to do
um and so people are more vulnerable to
that but I think on places like Twitter
you just block people nowadays you know
so it's not it's not as much of a thing
now it's uh you know if you don't want
to talk to somebody now you decide to
block them or you can mute them one of
the most interesting things that I see
on the internet is people who do
announce that they're going to one
follow somebody as if that announcement
of them are unfollowing them wasn't the
first time that that person they were
following had ever heard of them it's
like I I wasn't even aware of your
existence up until this moment but it's
like saying goodbye on the way out of
the door or like hello I don't know but
there's another one as well Godwin's law
to add on to this as an online
discussion grows the probability of a
comparison to Nazis our Hitler
approaches 100 most people are quick to
compare things to Nazi Germany because
it's the only history they know
yeah so I think this is an instance of
the availability heuristic so um one of
the ideas that comes most sort of
freshest to mind in people's minds when
they think of history is is Hitler and
the Nazis because it's one thing that we
constantly taught at school it's it's
the one thing that is is basically
because it's it's got all the sort of
it's got all the elements of a narrative
sort of uh box office smash you know
it's a story of good against evil uh to
an extent I mean if you don't include
styling on the Allies you know
um and it's basically about kind of you
know
um people who wanted freedom from
tyranny against essentially a tyrant and
the good guys weren't in the end you
know obviously this is a simplification
but this is the general sort of way it's
portrayed and um and it's it's just a
Timeless classic it's it's something
that you'd find in a movie and so
because it's so cinematic and because of
all the stuff involved I mean it's got
so many crazy stories in there you know
and the story of the Enigma machine
we've got Oppenheimer now which is going
to be a hit film and all these crazy
stories within the sort of remit of
World War II make it something that is
very memorable and a lot of people will
focus on that a lot of people who don't
know anything about history know about
World War II and they know about the
Nazis and they never think they know
they think they know about World War II
do you not know that Nazi was actually
socialist it was actually the part of
the Socialist Party and then it just
gets into a game of linguistic there
should be a rule you need to come up
with one uh which is
almost all arguments online
devolve into a game of lexical Brazilian
Jiu Jitsu over time because almost all
of it is just that's not the term that I
mean precisely you're using that word in
the wrong way what is the word woman in
any case do you not know that Nazi meant
socialist Nazis were far left not far
right Stalin wasn't do you know what I
mean absolutely yeah I mean there is
actually a uh a law uh about this
actually uh let me see if I can find it
in my list of rules because I've
forgotten the name of it but it's uh
there's actually a
uh let me just quickly go through them
right so I can find it uh so I find it
Lane's law so
um every debate is ultimately a debate
about the definition of words
um so for instance you know there are
many examples of this but one example
would be gender for instance so if
you're you know if there's an argument
between a gender critical person and a
transwise activist the debate will
almost always end with them discussing
what gender is
um and if there's a debate about free
will it will almost always end with them
discussing what free will is and
likewise socialism you know like
socialism will mean a different thing to
a leftist as it will mean to a right
rightist and so it's called Lane's law
and it's basically the the idea that
every debate ultimately is a debate
about the definition of words and I
think that's actually accurate I don't
think it's it's probably not like a
universal law it's not it's not true in
every single instance but I think it's a
true enough law that it's a good rule of
thumb agreed and that's why yeah I think
in most debates it becomes like a
contest between it's like one play one
person's playing tennis and one person
is playing baseball because
they using different definitions for
terms based on their tribe because every
tribe has got its own definitions you
know it has its own definitions of what
certain words mean and so when people
from two different tribes are arguing
they're using their own tribe's
definitions and that's why they'll never
ever see eye to eye and that's why if I
am going to debate somebody I don't
really do it very often but if I am
going to do it I'll always be sure to
ensure that I'm we're actually on the
same page in terms of definitions I
think that's absolutely essential
there's just no point in having any
debate unless you are willing to agree
on the definitions of words yup next one
arrival fallacy we didn't evolve to be
happy but to believe we'll be happy if
we just accomplish the latest goal so we
seldom taste true Joy but we often pick
up its scent just enough to keep us in
Pursuit Paradise is not a destination or
a journey but a horizon
yeah I think um so happiness we have to
ask ourselves why did happiness evolve
and obviously it didn't evolve for us to
you know meet one goal and then be
satisfied for the rest of our lives
because if we did that we wouldn't live
very long we would just fulfilled one
goal and then we would die because we
wouldn't have any motivation to do
anything else so in a sense
happiness is like a carrot constantly
being dangled in front of your your head
uh except it's tied to your head so
every time you move forward the carrot
moves forward so you're constantly
reaching for the carrot but you can't
quite get it and what this does is it
keeps you moving forward under the
impression that you're going to
eventually get that carrot but you will
never get the carrot because it's it's
tied to your head
um and this is I think is a good way of
looking at happiness this is not to say
that you can't ever be happy in your
life you will be happy in your life but
that happiness will never last you know
you'll you'll be happy for instance if
you save up to buy a nice car the day
you get that car you're going to be
happy you're going to be really happy
and you take it out for a test drive and
you impressive friends with it and you
know you'll be you'll you'll feel good
but within a couple of days you'll have
gotten used to having that car and it's
no longer going to bring you that same
joy and then you're going to want to
chase something else and this is the
process that a lot of people go through
in their lives where they're constantly
chasing something new because the things
that they have have not made them happy
and um Naval ravican he had this great
line where he said that desire is a
contract that you make with yourself to
be unhappy until you get what you want
and I think that's a good way of looking
at it where you're basically choosing to
be unhappy because you don't have this
thing that you're looking to get uh and
you're you basically tell yourself you
write this contract with yourself where
you'll only be happy if you can get that
thing but the thing is it's an illusion
because once you get it you're only
going to be happy for a short period of
time and I think
ultimately what I found in my life is
that the solution to this sort of
quandary is that you're not going to be
happy by accumulating possessions but by
relinquishing desires
so you have to learn to be happy with
less learn to appreciate the little
things in life and I found that since
I've done this I've just been so much
happier how do you link off desires
just to be content like with what you
have like this is a bit of a complex
thing and I'm going to tell you a bit of
a weird story but
um the other day I was in the
supermarket and I saw a tomato and I was
absolutely Overjoyed by this tomato I
just thought this tomorrow was
absolutely amazing I picked it up and it
was so plump and juicy and shiny and
bright and I loved it I thought this is
absolutely incredible and I was so happy
that I'd seen this tomorrow and you know
when I got home I ate this time and I
was really really happy about it and the
reason why that tomato made me really
happy was because I've actually thought
about the amount of work that it takes
to make a beautiful tomato like that
right this is like tomatoes originally
were not as delicious as they are now
they're originally not as beautiful as
they are now this is a product of many
many years many centuries of selective
breeding of cultivation of people
learning everything that they there is
to learn about agriculture and then over
many many years then passing this
knowledge down to their their sons and
daughters and then their sons and
daughters learning even more and then
passing that information down and all of
this this selective breeding of the
Tomato over many generations and the
knowledge of Agriculture of how to
create the perfect tomato and all of
this was done in order to create this
one tomorrow essentially
um to create this beautiful thing that
people want to eat and I when I think
about the amount of effort that it takes
to create something as beautiful as a
nice tomato something that feels really
good in the mouth something that has a
lot of flavor it makes me appreciate
that so much more and I think that a lot
of the value in things comes from
understanding just how lucky we are to
have them
and that's why I try to not to take
these things for granted right I I will
always try to look at how hard things
are to get for instance I am constantly
Amazed by the fact that I can eat food
from all over the world right without
even leaving my apartment right that is
absolutely incredible if you were to go
back in time to the 18th century and you
were to tell people that you could do
this in the future that you could just
pick up a device and talk on this device
and then within half an hour you could
have food from anywhere on the planet
delivered to your doorstep they would be
blown away they would think this is
you're living a life better than a king
have you heard have you heard the story
behind the first ever pineapple that was
imported to the United Kingdom
I'll send you the link afterward I
watched a YouTube video about it
absolutely fantastic so pineapples cost
I think the equivalent of 4 000 pounds
each in I want to say maybe late 1700s
something like that and it was just a
signal of opulence so opulent in fact
that people would get statues of
pineapples placed outside of their
family estates this is the sort of house
you're going into it's a house that eats
four thousand pound fruit like that this
is the kind of place and um yeah they're
talking about they're talking about the
the journey that this thing goes through
and then as soon as the first pineapple
is grown in the UK they're able to start
growing them in the UK
all of the pineapple monuments go down
because it's a counter signal you did a
great Thread about
um Marcus Aurelius as well there's a
quote from him that reminds me of what
you're talking about here do not indulge
in dreams of having what you have not
but reckon up the chief of the blessings
you do possess and then thankfully
remember how you would crave for them if
they were not yours gratitude for what
you have can cure the endless desire for
what you have not
yeah absolutely and that's what I do is
I think of my my life relative to say a
medieval peasant and how lucky I am and
you remind me a lot as a medieval
peasant actually
well I think a medieval peasant has a
lot of wisdom about them I think that
kind of Lifestyle appeals to me to be
honest um but like uh you know they to
them like the idea that of a person like
you and I that are living the kind of
you know we're talking to each other
from across the world like you're in the
states I'm in the UK and we're having an
ordinary conversation as though we were
sharing the same space you know this is
Magic to a medieval peasant
um the things that we do are absolutely
mind-blowing to pretty much all of human
history apart from to our generation
because we're used to it because to us
we're born into this world and so it
doesn't seem that special is here's the
crazy thing though if that peasant
there's nothing special about that
particular peasant himself it's simply
about the time that he was in if you
place that peasant into the modern world
and he was able to pick up the language
and do all of the things I bet within
five years he would have forgotten the
fact that he used to live in 1678 or
something and you're like the I was
imagining there in my mind what human
existence would be like if our hedonic
adaptation wasn't as powerful as it is
we'd be [__] because we wouldn't be
able to keep up with the pay case that
the world changes that there's a Morgan
household Court as well which is
phenomenal and he says the first rule of
winning the game is to stop moving the
goal posts he's talking about it in a uh
money saving psychology of of investing
perspective but it's so true when we're
thinking about the arrival fallacy you
know this belief
um that what we're moving toward that we
eventually we will be happy what is it
the uh
uh the that thing about the ideal that
you're moving toward was in fact your
death uh the not yet started life
fallacy or something
yeah um uh the uh something syndrome
um
I forgot what it's called now anyway I
know yeah yeah
it's a it's a rule that where people
presume that they will be happy when I
will be happy when I will be happy when
and then eventually what you realize is
the thing that you were putting off is
your death
Bill Perkins that wrote die with zeros
got another amazing quote where he says
um delayed gratification in the extreme
results and no gratification
and yes absolutely yeah you keep on
pushing it off
it's a case of finding a balance as with
most things in life I think you know um
we we are like in that quote that I the
original quote I said that we are all we
we often pick up the scent of Happiness
um and I think that that's what we need
to content ourselves with is the scent
of happiness because
we are like essentially happiness is a
reward system that we get in order to
motivate us all emotions are essentially
motivations and if we didn't feel desire
we wouldn't do anything like we would
literally just sit there and rot and
until we were dead because there would
be no motivation to do anything so the
desire there is actually a motivational
system and that little taste of
happiness that we get when we accomplish
a goal that is our reward for
accomplishing the goal so we can find
happiness you know in in fulfilling
basic goals but I think ultimately if
you want to be happy then you can't make
your happiness dependent on
circumstances because if you do that
then you'll never really often be happy
you're very seldom be happy and so it's
all about finding a state of mind in
which you are happy regardless of what
goes on in circumstances if you need a
reason to be happy you'll seldom be
happy yeah if you can't be happy with
the coffee you won't be happy with a
yacht that's another exactly absolutely
but yeah it's um
it's one of the hacks that I have found
that I think is effective for this this
comes from Tim Ferriss
um our anticipation of things is often
more enjoyable than the things
themselves so what you can do is extend
the enjoyment of The Thing by planning
lots and lots of stuff out far ahead me
and George Mack are going to anjuna deep
open air at Red Rocks in Denver in
November we've had this book for nine
months so I've been listening to
anjunadeep releases and albums and oh
there's a new DJ's been released for
this thing and I think definitely as you
get older you get
it seems I don't know much not juvenile
but maybe you're just too busy or
something you don't you don't excite
yourself as much about the idea of
future plans because you have so many
things to do in between now and the
plans to allow you to have the time to
go and enjoy the plans so I think that
definitely protracting that as much as
possible it's one of the you know I've
opened the broken the fourth wall about
this a million times on the show and
I'll continue to do it
I hack all of the audiences uh like
anticipation networks every single time
that I release a big episode I have this
[__] awful protracted drawn out
launch sequence who's it gonna be I I
recorded it in LA it's a person who's
friends with this person oh it's [__]
Sam Harris this is going to come out
just after a Sam Harris episode so no
one knows right now no one listening to
the show knows that it's going to be Sam
Harris then there'll be a teaser then
there'll be an announcement about Sam
then there'll be Clips then the episode
will drop because it gets people excited
and I would want that if I was a fan of
the show and I was a fan of Sam Harris I
would want to be like oh like Sam Harris
is coming on I can anticipate it a
little bit and I don't think that
there's anything nefarious or
manipulative about doing that I think it
allows people to enjoy the experience of
knowing that someone that they like is
going to do a thing that they're going
to enjoy for longer so speaking of
speaking of your peasant thing I had a
new one for you which I came up with
this is a collaboration between me and
Alex and the date site who is a great
Twitter follow this is the alpha history
fantasy modern men who are angry at a
world they believe has rejected them
mistakenly failed that they would have
done better in medieval times they are
somehow adamant that the chance of them
being Genghis Khan is greater than the
chance of them being Cannon for the
peasant number one million 373 000 whose
Favela was sacked and destroyed
that's a brilliant one I love that one
yeah absolutely
um I was I was reading this uh this
article yesterday about Bronze Age
pervert Yeah I read it as well I read
the same I read the same article yeah
yeah it's uh it's quite funny because
for your audience uh who might not know
who he is so he's a sort of far right
figure and when I say far right I
actually mean genuinely far right not
the kind of far right that you'll see on
Wikipedia you know but actual far right
like he's a he's a neo-reactionary so
he's like this guy basically believes
that a group of strong men should rule
over everybody with absolute Authority
um essentially and he's openly fascist
and stuff so uh this guy's become quite
popular sort of on the right and um
particularly um among certain people in
the Trump White House he was quite
popular they used to pass out pass
around his book um uh Brian's age
mindset and uh he's his whole thing is
basically about being strong it's about
um you know working out and having a
massive physique like his his avatar on
on Twitter is like this Hench like
jacked uh guy basically and he's all
about like you know um cultivating
physical strength and basically the
strongest should should Rule and the
weak should perish and all this and it's
hilarious because
his identity was actually
um sort of revealed against his wishes
and he's this guy called amariu who's
like a I think a Romanian immigrant to
the U.S and he's basically his actual
appearance he's he's like some scorny
little sort of pale kid like you know
who's who's nothing like he was
presenting himself out to be on Twitter
and on sort of you know on his Caribbean
Rhythms podcast because he was making
out like he was this massive bodybuilder
like Beefcake you know Monster basically
like a barbarian that's what he was his
whole thing is based around but in real
life he's like this really wimpy looking
like scrawny kid and like it's
absolutely hilarious because I think
that a lot of these people who claim
that they want to live in these you know
old sort of Genghis Khan style uh worlds
where you know it's just all about
brutality a lot of them wouldn't survive
like uh you know even a couple of days
they would be landed precisely on what
Alex started having an argument about
online so he came up with with half of
this and then I fleshed it out and gave
it the name
um and he was having an argument with
the at in sales co uh Twitter account
which is super super like
antagonistic and it like something
really fascinating to observe absolutely
fascinating to observe to be honest
he's having this big argument with them
and his point was hang on a second so
you are unsuccessful in the competence
dominance hierarchy and socio-sexually
with uh socioeconomically in terms of
being able to attract women sexually in
and somehow the belief is that half a
millennia ago
in 1523
you would have done better that do you
like a guy twice your size would have
worn you to [__] a girl with like there
is there he would have he would have
happily beheaded you he would have
happily taken your what you know so I I
do think that it's just an important
redress to the balance that things were
you know it was a purer time it was a
better time don't don't get me wrong way
I think that a lot of the people who
claim to want to live in a sort of
idyllic past are really yearning for
their childhood I think another a lot of
time because when they say that they
want a simpler time a simpler world that
is essentially their childhood that's a
world where things were much simpler
where you know they didn't have to worry
with all about all the kind of
complexities of adulthood and all that
kind of stuff so this is me being kind
of armchair psychologist here but like I
I do think that a lot of people really
are secretly yearning for their
childhood when they claim to want to
return to this idyllic past because this
idyllic past didn't actually ever exist
it's always been brutal like I mean
there was this one really um there's a
this this kind of far right another far
right uh um lady she's half Indian I
think her name's Mega or something and
she's a she's always tweeting about how
the past was so much better than the
present and she wrote this one thing
about how um
you know like in the past it was much
easier to grow food because all you had
to do was just have your own little
patch of land and then you could grow
any food you wanted and you know you had
enough to feel your whole family and
everything and it's just complete
nonsense because
the kinds of in the past food was so
hard to grow like you had to have the
perfect soil it had to with the perfect
pH uh you know you had to you had to
constantly ensure that insects weren't
getting at the food pests and stuff
um you had to ensure that the weather
was right there were so many things that
would just go wrong things that we take
for granted now right now we've got
pesticides we've got fertilizers uh
we've got like greenhouses we've got uh
UV sorry infrared lights we've got all
this um different stuff that helps stuff
grow right we can grow stuff at length
now we can grow as much food as we want
but this wasn't always the case it
wasn't food wasn't always there's
plentiful in the past your crops could
fail like within a day like you know you
could you could be you could have a
massive field of crops and within a day
they could get ruined by a single flood
you know it was we were completely at
the mercy of nature um you know and
people don't seem to realize this people
seem to think that oh you know living in
the past is just like um living around
nature man you know like just basically
yeah free love like the people and this
is true of the trads on the right as
well as as the kind of the kind of
hippies that you might find who are more
on the left but like it's it's this sort
of idealization of the past one that you
just don't one that doesn't reflect
reality I wonder if a lot of the stuff I
wonder if we could fold in that like the
horticulturalists history fantasy as
well or that the agriculturalist history
fantasy as well as the Alphas
exactly you know there's for instance
like there you know there's
if you look at sort of the famines that
are happening in places like Sudan for
instance and Somalia those things were
widespread they were happening
everywhere at one point
um and the only reason they don't happen
in the west anymore is because we have
the technology to prevent them from
happening so this is not like oh you
know we're just looking at uh to to
because Nature's on our side and nature
wants us to eat well no nature doesn't
give a [__] about us you know Nature's
Nature's desires are not aligned with us
if it wants to ruin our crops it will
just ruin our crops it doesn't care
about what humans want and you know
entire populations in the past died of
starvation we are lucky because we are
the ones that descended from those who
just happen to to make it here's another
way to look at it so for the people that
are on the left that would maybe um you
know the climate 100 years ago it was so
much more balanced look at these extreme
weather events that we're having etc etc
climate related deaths have decreased by
98 in the last century there's been a
50x decrease and more people die from
cold weather than dry from hot weather
more people die from cold than die from
heat and there's been a 50 50x decrease
in climate related deaths over the last
century so you know I think yeah you're
right there's there's something going on
whereby
if
if you can convince yourself that a past
time would have been better
it alleviates some of the pressure of
now not being as good as it could be
because you are no longer culpable for
the reason that it's not as good as it
could be ah I've outsourced this the the
challenges that I'm facing to the fact
that there is something structural or
systemic or systematic that's stopping
it from happening
yeah absolutely I think there is a
desire for people to blame
to shift the blame to things outside of
themselves and um I mean I'll cover this
in in my my most recent article
um where we've seen this happen actually
a bit more it's actually quite
disturbing how um I think Jonathan
height and Gene twang uh they found that
there has been an externalization of the
locus of control so for your audience uh
the locus of control is the degree to
which one believes that they as opposed
to external circumstances shape their
Destiny so people who have an internal
locus of control they believe that their
own decisions are what dictate what
happens in their life and people who
have an external locus of control they
believe that what they do doesn't really
matter because their lives are dictated
by what happens in the external world
and interestingly uh there seems to have
been an externalization of the locus of
control over the past sort of 40 years
and particularly since the 1990s
um I actually think that people in the
in the distant past didn't have the
luxury of having an X
most of the time I mean there was still
scapegoating and things like that when
people form tribes but I think when
you're trying to survive you don't have
that luxury you don't have the luxury of
uh you know blaming other things you
have to take responsibility for for
what's going wrong in your life but when
you arrive in in a world like ours where
pretty much everything is done for you
you have that luxury you can now
suddenly start blaming everything else
except for yourself and that's why I
think we have these people who are
yearning for this distant past where you
know everything was in their eyes much
better because they can easily just
blame the Modern Age it's easy to blame
identity because you don't have to take
responsibility for me because virginity
is doing everything for you modernity is
growing your food modernity is keeping
you safe from uh invasions modernity is
keeping you warm you know modernity is
giving you the information that you need
to help yourself in pretty much any
situation that you could possibly find
yourself in modernity is a map for you
that you can find your way through
anywhere you know modernity gives you
pretty much everything and that allows
you the luxury to blame modernity for
your problems yeah there's a there's one
there's one that I came up with the
existential crisis luxury only when the
bottom levels of Maslow's hierarchy are
filled can you ask questions like am I
truly self-actualizing therefore having
a crisis of Life direction should be a
reason for gratitude not despondency
absolutely we are so lucky you know to
have what we have gratitude is something
that in order to have the kinds of
problems we have we have to be living
lives that are essentially you know this
the whole thing about first world
problems you know this is this is what
we worry about most of the time now we
were pretty much I would say 90 of my
problems now our first world problems am
I enacting my Logos am I speaking my
truth forward is this really my highest
self showing up day today
yeah and this is why you know it's
you know if you look at the kinds of
things that people are talking about now
if people are talking about trauma for
instance
trauma has become probably one of the
most common buzzwords in the world today
um in the in the west and what trauma
means now
is it usually just means being a little
bit disappointed whereas what trauma
meant in the past would probably mean
something I'll have your arm cut off you
know so there's been a there's been a
massive amount of concept creep with
regard to what we really regard as a
problem
um because we live lives of such luxury
now uh the people sort of who were
living 200 300 years ago they would
probably be laughing at our problems
they would be just considering I I don't
disagree and I'm I'd sing from the same
hymn sheet as yourself but as we said
before hedonic adaptation is a hell of a
drug and it's going to continue to come
in and whatever the opposite of hedonic
adaptation but for how you begin to zero
in on an Ever more high resolution high
standard High bar that you want from
your life and I don't think that this is
necessarily a bad thing for society to
do either if we were to say we only need
to have health care standards that are
at the level that they were in the 1800s
despite the fact that we've made all of
this progress that would be a rejection
of the responsibility we have with our
newly increased capacity so it is
important both structurally and
individually to continue to ask more
from yourself it's the balance as with
everything the virtuous mean as with
everything you're trying to find where
is the middle ground where is the
balance between these two different
things
yeah absolutely
um I wrote this tweet actually which I
think speaks to this uh quite a bit and
it's basically about uh and this
basically this it's um everything about
Humanity has improved throughout history
except contentment but it is only
because our contentment never improves
that we keep improving everything else
and I think that that kind of speaks to
what you were saying which which is
basically that it's it's essential to
progress we have to be uncomfortable in
order to progress we have to keep we
have to always find ways that the world
could be better in order to make the
world better and so I agree with you
completely you know we do need to have
this kind of sense of you know this kind
of hedonic adaptation is it's not just a
good it's necessary it's absolutely
necessary because if it weren't we would
just be we would never we would never
progress as a species we would just be
content with what we have so I think
like I said it's a case of balancing
um what we have with what we want so we
should be grateful for what we have and
and that's what I am I'm absolutely
grateful for everything I have but that
doesn't mean that I don't want more I
can still want more and still be
grateful for what I have and that's it's
a bit of a weird sort of line to to
balance but it can be done
um because you can always find new
things to one that's that's the easiest
thing in the world the harder thing is
to be find some sort of value in what
you already have and I think just
finding that balance is is the key to
being happy I think yes it's definitely
made a difference to me have I told you
about that story I learned about uh the
Buddha's quote of life is suffering so
the word suffering is Duca d-u-k-k-h-a
and some Scholars argue contest that
it's not suffering but
unsatisfactoriness life is
unsatisfactoriness and I think that that
makes an awful lot more sense that it's
always just about going to be
behind where your anticipation and your
expectation were because your
expectation is built to be out ahead of
what reality can deliver to you okay
next one next one uh Saint George in
retirement syndrome many who fight
Injustice come to Define themselves by
their fight against Injustice so that as
they defeat the Injustice they must
invent new injustices to fight against
simply to maintain their identity
yeah I think this is a product of people
uh sort of tying their their mission
with their identity
so people will come out and they will
have some kind of political cause where
they'll be like you know oh I absolutely
hate racism or something and then
they'll go out there and be like
anti-racist you know but what they will
do is they'll make the mistake of tying
their status as an anti-racist with
their identity and they will actually
make that part of their identity so they
will begin to Define themselves as an
anti-racist
and the dangerous thing with this is
that if they do eventually defeat racism
then their identity is essentially
nullified they no longer have any
meaning they're not just out of a job
they're out of personhood as well
exactly and they've lost their sense of
purpose they've lost their meaning in
their life they've lost their kind of
narrative because we all view Our Lives
as narratives we're all kind of like
movie characters living a movie and if
you've basically defeated the villain
then there's no point in continuing the
movie you know that's it the movie's
over
role credits so these people
unfortunately what they uh how they tend
to respond is that they will sort of
increase the uh they will project new
racisms in the world they will uh create
new cause of new dragons to slay
basically and you can see this in the
phenomenon of concept creep where
you know when we defeat one form of harm
we will expand the definition of that
harm so that it covers more things so um
for instance uh racism is is the obvious
one so racism obviously there's still
racism but it if we look at how it was
with Jim Crow Jim Crow was uh was actual
genuine hardcore systemic racism where
you had two tiers of society you had
white people and you had black people
and then the civil rights movement and
everything kind of just destroyed that
and then the the definition of racism
was expanded so then you had
institutional racism you had systemic
racism and then you had these new
subspecies of racism you had
microaggressions cultural appropriation
and basically the kind of definition of
racism just kept expanding because as
racism was gradually removed from
society people needed to retain that
sense that they were fighting a great
threat and so they expanded it and like
I said this is not to say that racism
doesn't still exist it does still exist
but it's nowhere near the problem that
it was 100 years ago or even further
back so as racism has become less of an
actual threat people have expanded their
definition of it in order to give
themselves a purpose in order to retain
this sense that they are slaying this
this Mighty dragon
and if someone lets go of that then who
am I who am I exactly after all of this
has happened
yeah I think yeah people this is one of
the the things why it's almost pointless
to argue with an activist because they
have tied their identity to their
activism so if you are arguing with
their cause if you're saying that their
cause is meaningless you're basically
saying that their life is meaningless
you're basically saying that their their
entire identity is meaningless you know
like if you were to go to Ibraham
Kennedy and tell him look racism is
nowhere near them as much of a problem
as you say is
that's going to be a personal attack
against him because he spent his whole
life writing about racism
and so this it comes across as a
personal attack they view it as a
personal attack it's not just a
political disagreement it becomes an
actual attack on their whole sort of
system of identity uh the way that
they've they form sort of this uh
self-conception uh which makes it very
sort of hard to argue with these people
because why do you think it is that
people are attaching their sense of self
their sense of self-worth uh integrating
art and artists together in in this way
is this a surrogate for religion is this
that a lot of cultural Technologies
previously would have been so Central to
the way that we see the world is it just
that the Allure of Fame and status and
continuing to you know uphold whatever
the cause is allows you to keep charging
forward have you got any idea of the
post-mortem there I would say that it's
probably many different factors because
obviously humans do things for a variety
of different reasons and I think all of
the reasons that you just mentioned are
probably they all probably play a part
so I'd say yeah absolutely the the
meaning crisis has contributed to this a
lot you know there's there's this kind
of vacuum that people are now trying to
fill with obviously with the death of
God people are trying to fill this
vacuum with whatever they can and some
people are choosing to fill it with
social justice and the last time I was
on this podcast we spoke of atheism plus
um being a kind of surrogate for for it
was a way that the new atheists tried to
retain a sense of purpose and meaning
was by going for social justice
um so I think that's definitely part of
it and then I think that there are other
people who perhaps are looking for clout
online looking for some kind of uh you
know some sense of belonging or
something you know they want a big part
they want to have a kind of uh an
audience
um you know or are trying to belong to
and a Hilton as well yeah and able to
die on you know there's so there are
many things many reasons why people do
and they're obviously they're probably
just people who genuinely have been
fooled into believing that racism is
more common than it actually is or you
know that misogyny is more common than
it actually is or whatever like you know
whatever cause you wanna you wanna talk
about I mean I was one of those people I
used to believe racism was more common
than it actually was because I used to
get all my information from the guardian
and the New York Times and this was
around the time when we had the great
awokening where there was a 400 increase
in the use of words like sexism and
racism in the the liberal media and I
was reading at that time so I developed
this idea that you know everybody was
racist and all this kind of stuff and
that goes back to what you said before
about a well-curated social media feed
is either Heaven or Hell uh okay next
one opinion shopping maybe many who can
worked research online ignore every
Source they disagree with till they find
one they agree with and then use this
source as an authority to justify what
they already believe they don't consider
someone an expert unless they agree with
them
so this is one that hits quite close to
home because I used to do this I was
guilty of this
um when I was when I first sort of like
got onto Twitter and stuff and I used to
engage people in arguments what I would
do is whenever I wanted to prove
something uh to to my interlocutor what
I would do is I would type in what I
wanted to prove so
um so basically you know like so like
let's say if I wanted to prove that
let's just say something randomly I
wanted a proof that the world was flat
you know I would just type in
um evidence that the world is flat and
then I would get obviously I would get
some kind of evidence from some Fringe
website and then I would basically say
hey look see look this is proof that the
world is flat so you know I think this
is something that a lot of people do and
the reason I think that a lot of people
do this is because I've also seen other
people do it I've in fact they've done
it in arguments with me like um for
instance what would happen is that I
would I would say oh um what evidence is
there for claim X and and then they
wouldn't respond for like an hour or
something and then
eventually they would they would
basically um
post this link to this article or
whatever which was which claims to
represent what they say it claims and
then what I would do is I'd go on Google
and I would type in uh what they'd you
know what they were trying to prove and
immediately would be the first first
search result and I'd see okay so what
you've done is you've basically just
you've gone on to Google you've you've
typed in something you've ignored all
the search results which disagree with
your position and pick the one which
agrees with it and then you've held the
support you've put a prompt in that is
only going to give you things that
confirm your worldview you haven't
exactly but even isn't the world flat
yeah you've also you've looked for the
world is for that evidence yeah that's
the first thing but then even within
that they'll Google will sometimes will
you know say this is a myth or whatever
and then they'll just skip that
completely and they'll go to the one
yeah and and I think this is you know
people compare it to maybe confirmation
bias so it is a similar sort of
mechanism to confirmation bias except
the difference is that confirmation bias
is uh unconscious it's it's something
that you do unwitting whereas opinion
shopping is a conscious action it's when
you consciously are looking for
information that supports your worldview
yeah very good yeah yeah so I do think
that this is a very very common thing
because if you are good enough at
Googling in fact you don't even need to
be very good at Googling if you know
basic English you can always get pretty
much any academic study or any kind of
New York Times article or whatever that
just supports what you're trying to
prove and then you can just hold it hold
it up as proof of what you're you know
like anytime somebody says that they've
got evidence of something if you do a
Google you can always find evidence to
the contrary because and this probably
goes to another concept that was in one
of my mega threads
um which is the idea that for every PhD
there is an equal and opposite PhD
Gibson's law yeah it matters in matters
of Law and policy anyone can find a
subject matter expert who supports their
view because having a PhD doesn't
necessarily make someone right it often
just makes them more skilled at being
wrong
yeah and this is this is something
that's
a sort of very common in um sort of Law
Courts in fact I think many of your
audience might have watched the Johnny
Depp trial where you know when him
against Amber Heard uh which was last
year and anybody who watched that trial
will have noticed that both uh both
people drew on psychologists and
psychiatrists to support their candidate
uh their their sort of um defendant or
whatever I think candidate I think
candidate's probably more accurate yeah
yeah or plaintiff or whatever but like
yeah I mean um so you know they what
what happened is that you had two groups
of psychiatrists and psychologists both
of them were equally qualified they're
both you know that both groups had phds
from pretty respectable universities
because they had they were you know
being paid by Hollywood actors so they
were the cream of the crop
um so these were prestigious
psychiatrists and yet they had
completely opposite conclusions to what
was going on and so what you see here is
obviously these two groups cannot both
be right at the same time their opinions
are mutually exclusive and so there's
only one thing that could be happening
here which is that they are
rationalizing they are they're cherry
picking evidence to support the
narrative that they want to push and
this I think is a very sort of good
microcosm of what goes on in the real
world where you have experts who are
drawn on not just by um you know by
lawyers and by legal teams but by
businesses and you see this uh with with
regards to say um for instance in the in
the corporate world in business
what what happened is in fact the
original term opinion shopping
originally comes from the business world
because what businesses would do is that
they would hire experts who agreed with
them to write papers that agreed with
what they were trying to do so for
instance Coca-Cola would hire
nutritionists who uh would say that you
know oh um sugar isn't actually that bad
for you for instance you know the main
thing that you want to be worrying about
is salt and fat those are much more
worse for you than sugar obviously this
you know this has been shown to be not
quite true but
um the the issue was that they wanted to
make people believe that coke was
healthy so they would cherry pick
experts they would you know they would
find experts who had done research which
they thought they could use to their
advantage and then they would pay this
person to write a report on their behalf
uh which would you know and you see this
everywhere now you see it uh in gender
clinics so you know for instance kids or
basically the the Tavistock you know
they they were pretty cushy with
mermaid's charity and um with other
similar Charities and what they would do
is they would they would work with
academics who believed what they
believed people like Jack turbine who's
a well-known gender ideologue in
Academia and they would they would
basically pay these people to write
academic papers using their expertise
using their uh their sort of their
knowledge to make the case for for
instance giving puberty blockers to
underage kids or whatever like you know
to young young children and then you
know just to be balanced there would
probably be people on the opposite side
of this aisle who would do the opposite
they would get the they would get the um
the experts that agreed with them to
write papers to do the same things and
that's that really is a lot of Academia
is fueled by this it's fueled by
institutions paying academics to make
the case for why that institution is
great in other words basically but to do
it indirectly by just by doing its
studies and these studies are usually
quoted and widely quoted by the Press so
this is another reason why you can't
really believe what you read in the
Press because even the academic studies
that quoted by these media Outlets or
often they are often a result of
perverse incentives there's a quote that
I put in my newsletter today from Nat
Friedman that says better to get your
dopamine from improving your ideas than
having them validated
yeah because it feels good nowadays yeah
absolutely and nowadays what I do is I
don't really read
um work from authors that I agree with
very often anymore I do sometimes you
know because I feel like I mainly just
so that I can kind of um
boost them you know retweet them or
whatever like you know I want to retweet
some people that I agree with uh so I
naturally will read it first but like
usually what I would do now nowadays is
I will actually seek out information
from people I disagree with because I
find that's just so much more valuable
to me I learn so much more from reading
people that I think I disagree with and
I say think because I'm not always sure
whether I will disagree with them but
people that I assume that I would
disagree with because they're on they're
in a different tribe or whatever you
know
um so like recently I've been I've been
reading the works of um people like
Julius Butler this is going back to the
whole gender thing again because I've
never really considered her worldview
very much I mean obviously I was
familiar with her work but uh because
she's blamed for a lot of this kind of
gender ideology kind of stuff and so I
thought I'd better get to the first get
right to the source instead of reading
what people are saying about her which
is what I've been doing for the past few
years I thought I'd actually better get
to the source itself and actually read
what she's actually said and to be fair
to her I mean she still strikes me as a
little bit crazy but not as crazy as
she'd be made out to be by people like
Chris Ruffo
um you know and other people like that
so
you know it's I think it's important for
getting a balanced View and it's also I
have learned things that I wouldn't
otherwise have learned because the kinds
of circles that I move in I would never
have gotten the ideas that Judith Butler
is is putting out I would only have
gotten
um sort of
Straw Men of those kinds of ideas even
though I I would regard my the people
that I hang out with as being pretty
reasonable and being pretty fair-minded
even then they are still human beings so
they're going to have the prejudices
that a human being has and you've
selected them right you've chosen them
to be around you so your biases are at
play just with the selection effect
there yes yeah I've got one I got one
here that I stole from Naval you quoted
Naval earlier on and this is uh real
world karma karma doesn't need Quantum
energy or spiritual woo to be real karma
is just you repeating your patterns
virtues and flaws until you finally get
what you deserve
so I think Naval meant this in a when he
said this he meant it in a very specific
context right he meant it in the context
of
um whether you work hard or whether you
don't or you know basically if you work
hard you will eventually get the fruits
of your labors and if you don't you
won't I don't think that Karma exists in
any any kind of capacity in the in the
wider world I mean history is filled
with with nasty nasty people who got
away with with everything in the end and
we live very happy lives so and on that
contrary history is also filled with
people who you know did nothing but help
other people and then ended up getting
Betrayed at the end so I don't think
Karma exists in any kind of real sense
of the world but I think it does exist
in the sense that maybe I think Navarre
means it which is that
you get the fruits of your own labors
with regards to productivity and
um so if you if you feel like you know
you're you're not worth anything and you
don't really you're not willing to put
in the work because you just feel like
you know what's the point and you don't
really have any agency then that's the
self fulfilling proper prophecy you know
you won't get you won't get what you
want in life but if you if you are
adamant on getting what you want and you
you put everything that you want to what
you know you basically sacrifice the
present for the future
um within reason as we were saying
before
um then you will get what you want and
you'll get essentially what you deserve
and more when he says the word deserve I
hate the word deserve because I don't
even know what the word deserve means
you know it basically implies a value
judgment of some kind yeah what does it
even mean nature doesn't have any
concept or deserve it doesn't there is
no concept you know nature just gives
people things um based on cause and
effect there is no deserve and so
um
I do think that people deserve things
only in the sense that did they put in
the work yeah I think if I was to if I
was to reread the deserve bit at the end
uh karma is just you repeating your
patents virtues and flaws until you
finally get what you deserve for me it's
until you finally get what is likely
it's uh the way that I think about it
when I read that quote is um people
rolling Dice and it also relates back to
this internal external locus of control
thing that you mentioned earlier on
which is if you believe that you have an
internal locus of control if you
continue to roll the dice over and over
and your patterns virtues and flaws
suggest that you are going to get this
is not to say that there are people as
you mentioned before perfectly Noble
virtuous high integrity people who work
hard who at the end of their life or
part way through their life have some
catastrophe that they it wasn't
basically their fault uh absolutely that
can happen but the more times that you
roll the dice and the more effective
your inputs are the less likely it is
that that's going to happen right the
the the uh yeah I agree with that yeah
yeah I think yeah that's a good way of
of looking at it I think um yeah it's
it's I think yeah it it really comes
down to like we can't control
probability but we can control the
probability space
so we can control the range of outcomes
but we can't control the specific
outcome so for instance if you don't
work hard then there is no chance that
you're ever going to succeed because
that's not within the probability space
that you've created but if you work hard
then then you are creating that
probability space you you're putting
that as one of the possible outcomes you
can have and so I think in that sense
yes you will get what you deserve in
that sense
um because you are essentially you are
creating the the branching tree of
possibilities that exist ahead of you
and so you'll get one of those outcomes
mismatch Theory moths evolved to
navigate by the moon a good strategy
until the invention of electric lamps
which now lead them astray equally
humans evolve to be tribal a good
strategy until the digital age where it
now leads us to act like polarized goons
online
I think this is everything I think this
theory is the foundation of pretty much
all of our problems in the Modern Age
the fact that we have created for
ourselves a world that we didn't evolve
for
uh you know where our our sort of the
majority of our Evolution and adaptation
occurred over sort of 300 000 years when
we were on the African savannas and
that's the world that we that our brains
are configured for and
pretty much everything that happens now
is a result of this these evolved
behaviors behaviors that we evolved for
the African Savannah from hunt together
a lifestyle not
being of much use in this new
environment in which we find ourselves
in so that the tribal thing is the one
is one aspect of it you know we are
obviously when we're when you're living
in the African Savannah as a
hunter-gatherer it makes sense to be
tribal because if you're not tribal
you're not going to survive very long on
your own you know you need you need the
cooperation of other people and you need
to have a common purpose and a common
sense of unity because if you don't then
the another tribe that does have a
common sense of purpose is going to
completely wipe you out so a lot of
these things and this is particularly
true of belief for me so belief forming
you know we sort of naively often
believe that people believe things
because they think they're true but
that's just not true at all uh what's
actually the sort of main driver of
beliefs I think a particularly this is
particularly true of political beliefs
is whether those beliefs help us in a
social context so if they can make
people like us or if they can give us a
kind of identity something to belong to
a common purpose with other people
and this is a wrote another article
about this actually uh the white smart
people believe stupid things
um there's an idea
um called
um by a psychologist called Dan Kahan or
Kahan I don't know how you pronounce it
if it's k-a-h-a-n and he had an idea
called identity protective cognition
which is
this idea that when people form beliefs
what they're doing is they're looking at
other people and seeing how these
beliefs uh operate in a social context
so if if having a certain belief makes
people very very popular and if it makes
a lot of other people love them then
that makes you feel that that belief is
more true
and this is a mechanism that is designed
to essentially allow us to form beliefs
with people that will allow people to
like us and that will allow us to have
status and a sort of sense of belonging
and to have this tribal sort of
um Arrangement around us you know so
that it's it's a way of arranging tribes
it's a way of forming these kind of
hierarchies so if you um you know if you
believe something uh that everybody
around you believes they're gonna like
you and this is something that everybody
knows if you have the same beliefs as
somebody they will like you a lot more
that's a system that's that's basically
a a gluing system it's a way that glues
people together into tribes and allows
them to form a common purpose and then
allows them to succeed on this on the
plains of Africa
unfortunately that doesn't work so well
in this age where we now have a lot of
sort of partisan thinking we have people
forming online tribes engaging in
misinformation online where people are
posting information that they agree with
but not information that's necessarily
true and so the whole system has been
sort of torn apart by this new way that
we're living you know now it doesn't
bring us we don't really form mobs
anymore we don't form at least we don't
form them in the real world we form
online but we don't form these tribes
that would help each other out
physically in the real world anymore now
we form mobs online and we go after
people and we've you know we have
scapegoats and we have uh you know this
kind of bickering with other tribes and
all of this is not serving any of us
well it's not actually doing anything
for us all it's doing is it's making us
angry it's uh making us bitter it's it's
making us fight with people on the other
side of the world who we're never going
to meet in real life it's
um making us push out information that's
not true and you know fake narratives
everywhere it's causing indoctrination
it's causing people to be distracted
from what they really want to achieve in
their lives so all of these negative
consequences have emerged from what was
once an asset you know which has now
become a liability as a result of this
new way that we're living and this is
just one aspect of the mismatch Theory
the the mismatch Theory can be applied
to so many different aspects of Life
another aspect is that our brains are
sort of evolved to operate when when
we're moving
this is uh this is a lesser known thing
but we're supposed to be moving all the
time pretty much we're supposed to be on
the on foot uh traveling vast distances
and that's good for our body because
that's how our BR that's how our body's
evolved our bodies evolved for movement
but now we spend most of our lives
indoors sitting in a sedentary position
and so the system like our blood system
uh the circulatory system is sort of
evolved for movement it it's supposed to
it's it's created under this sort of
assumption that a being is going to be
moving but we're not doing that we're
just sitting still for long periods of
time and so our circulatory systems are
not operating efficiently our Bloods you
know blood's not efficiently
um sort of oxygenating our organs and as
a result that we're having many health
problems now
the best way that anyone who is unsure
whether or not that hypothesis is real
can prove it to themselves think about
the last time that you took a phone call
and you needed to think hard while
you're on the phone a huge proportion of
people will find themselves just as if
some hand has been placed inside of them
they'll stand up and they'll start
pacing around the room and absolutely I
learned this from Kelly I do that all
the time yeah Kelly Starrett says that
we're built to locomote and that our
brains work better when we're locomoting
and you know if there was a way that I
could do a podcast that didn't look too
weird because if I was if I was doing
this on some sort of treadmill as I'm
bouncing up and down and there may be a
bit of noise but yeah I am I totally
agree and I think that yeah it's why
walking is so good for writing you know
when I wasn't walking when I when I just
used to wake up in the morning and then
go to my desk and write it would take me
ages to actually come out with good
ideas but I began sort of about
shortly there's actually quite recent it
was about three months ago since I moved
into these new players I've been going
for walks every day pretty much and I've
found that the number of ideas that I've
come out with is just so Stark and I
mean this is something that writers
throughout history have said as well
it's not just me it's not you know it's
not just something I discovered just now
but writers throughout history have
recommended walking like Nietzsche for
instance Nietzsche used to go for long
walks in the Swiss Alps uh when he was
recovering uh from uh some sort of
depression or anxiety that he had they
didn't call it depression back in the
day but but he had some kind of mental
problems and he he went out into
um Swiss Alps and he'd go for long walks
and he said that he didn't trust any
idea that he didn't come out with unless
it was while he was walking so you know
it was uh so basically any idea that he
came up with what he was seeing at desk
he didn't trust that idea and I mean I
feel almost yeah I wouldn't go quite
that far but I think that you know I
walking is just such a if you have an
idea while sat at the desk make sure
that you still believe it after you've
gone for a walk that's not a bad yeah
that's not a bad razor to use okay next
one
just because someone is intelligent
doesn't mean their intelligence is
pursuing intelligent goals it's possible
to devote a genius level intelligence to
justify idiotic opinions and behaviors
so in artificial intelligence research
there is something called the
orthogonality thesis
and what this says is that basically
just because uh and a machine is an
intelligently pursuing a goal it doesn't
mean that the goal itself is intelligent
so you know a standard sort of uh
illustration of this idea would be the
pay-per-click maximizer so the
pay-per-click maximizerism is a machine
that is it's a hypothetic hypothetical
thankfully hypothetical machine which
has been programmed to create as many
paper clips as possible
and it's basically been programmed to
have this as its absolute priority to
basically override all of the priorities
and so what this machine does is it
begins to turn literally everything on
the planet into paper clips and when the
engineers realize what they've done and
they go to change it they go to
re-deprogram it it turns them into paper
clips because if it were to not then
they would have there would be fewer
paper clips and so it ends up taking
turning the whole world into paper clips
and so it does something extremely
stupid but it does it in a very
intelligent way
and this really is a good sort of sort
of metaphor for the human brain
because just because somebody is
intelligent and just because somebody
has a high IQ it doesn't mean that that
intelligence is being put into the
service of intelligent goals uh it's
very very possible to to have very very
stupid opinions like really stupid
conclusions but to very intelligently
reason for them yeah fortified fortified
with an absolute genius level Armory
around it exactly and you see this a lot
in Academia you know people who have
their whole lives they're just they're
sort of spend their whole lives in their
head and they become very good at
thinking but they use that thinking to
come out with the most wackiest ideas
because they want to be original
because if you're if you're in Academia
you want to you you want two things you
want to be interesting and you want to
be original and you know because there's
a publication bias in favor of those two
things and so uh you have to say
something that nobody else is saying and
you have to say something that shocks
people or surprises people and so you
see a lot of academics Who come out with
the most insane opinions
um and then they will use their
intelligence which is usually quite
considerable they'll use that
intelligence to justify that the most
moronic opinions
um you know I read this uh this one
laughable study uh which was conducted
uh by this uh by this author who said
that basically rape didn't exist in
America until white people uh arrived on
its Shores and then they introduced rape
to the Native Americans you know just
completely bizarre idea that they're
basically saying that Native Americans
were innocent didn't have they didn't
ever commit any sexual assault they
always think about it Comanches Indians
as being a very very civilized people up
until the point at which they were
invaded yeah exactly then white people
taught them how to rape and that's why
rape exists in America amongst the
Native Americans completely like idiotic
opinion but this author then used like
all these weird sort of really weird
esoteric knowledge about uh peculiar
things that happened in history
um then basically got like scientific
studies really really cherry-picked you
know just to kind of create this now
yeah which is some very special
narrative together yeah exactly and this
was doing this required a lot of
intelligence because they had to get
information from very disparate fields
and sort of combine them together and
you know create this weird argument
which when you when you look at the
album I mean it's a complete nonsense
argument but it's very intelligently put
together it's taken a lot of effort
clearly because there's so much research
involved do you know what it makes me
think of it makes me think about the
four stoic virtues so Justice Temperance
courage and wisdom and without the
fourth one which I think is going to be
the final book that Ryan writes in his
series on the the four virtues
um without the fourth one all of the
previous ones can be deployed in a
stupid way that you know you can be
courageous For A Cause which is
pointless that you can be just towards
something which doesn't require it that
your Temperance can be used in in the
wrong sort of way so
um yeah there is a I don't even know
what it's it's cognition and
metacognition almost right it's like
being able to step out a George Mack
calls it um clouds and dirt so he says
that you need to get down to the level
of the Frog and you need to get up
toward the level of the birds see the
map make sure that the map and the
terrain are still different go down go
do the work come back up make sure that
I'm still doing the right thing go back
down yes absolutely yeah I mean I would
say that
um it's like looking through a
microscope and a telescope at the same
time you've got to look at both you've
got to see the big picture and then
you've got to focus in and zero on on
the details and most you know a lot of
academics will just look at the
microscope they'll they'll just zero in
on a very tiny part of the picture and
they'll use their intelligence to
interpret that that little picture but
they won't look at the greater scheme of
things and I think ultimately it comes
down to having intelligent goals because
if you can create intelligent goals then
you have some kind of Guiding Light you
have a you have a North star by which
you can navigate
but one of the problems is that people
don't have intelligent goals they they
just have like a very simple goal
um and then they would you know they'll
in many cases what they would do is
they'll begin with a conclusion and
they'll just say okay I need to get to
that that conclusion any way I can
and then they will rationalize their way
to that conclusion and this is a big
danger I think is that when you reason
backwards instead of Reason forwards yes
so
um most people like will begin with that
conclusion and they'll try and look for
a way to get there so uh if you're a
very very intelligent person you'll
always find a way to get there you'll
always find a way to get there no matter
what no matter how crazy the conclusion
is and you've just got to look at the
number of
books with crazy Theses you know and
just by intelligent people just to know
this is true I could
you know if I wanted to I could come out
I could basically have a really really
insane conclusion a really insane goal
um so it would be something like um
again if I wanted to prove that the
world is flat right I could I could
begin from that assumption and then I
could put every waking day researching
any piece of information that would
possibly be used to rationalize that
argument and I could create a book out
of it I could actually do that you know
but it would take me a long time and it
I would really be frying my brains
trying to do it but I could do it I
think so I could create a compelling
argument that the world is flat By
ignoring all the information that I
don't like and focusing only on the
information that I like and this is why
intelligent people often believe stupid
things because the capacity for
reasoning is also the capacity for
rationalization
uh you know rationality is not something
that comes naturally to people
rationalization is something that comes
naturally to people we are again this
goes back to Identity protective
cognition Dan kahan's idea the idea is
that intelligence evolved not
to help us to find the truth it evolved
to help us to survive and if surviving
requires us to believe crazy beliefs
like if we're living in North Korea for
instance it makes much more sense for
our intelligence to help us to believe
that Kim Jong-un is the Son of God or
whatever you know he's like a Divine
being and that he was born on a mountain
and that the Birds Sang his praise when
he was born you know obviously a normal
person wouldn't couldn't believe that
but if you're intelligent you can
convince yourself of that and you know
this is something that throughout
history we needed to do we needed to
believe we need to convince ourselves or
at least imagine it might at least
pretend that we believed a crazy belief
so either we were good at acting and
pretending that we believe something
that we don't or we could generally
convince ourselves of that beliefs and
both of those things require
intelligence so our intelligence was
used to make us believe [__] it was
made it was specifically configured and
calibrated to help us to believe things
that are not true because they would
help us survive in the social context
one of my favorite explanations for why
we have theory of mind and why we have
Consciousness at all is that it allows
us to model what other people are
thinking about us so in a very Nimble
and complex social structured species
like we are that have moving power
dynamics and I know that that person
doesn't quite like that person and they
used to be in favor with this one and
what do they think about me and how did
I show up and blah blah the whole point
is to portray as best as possible to the
outside world that we are not insane
I am a totally normal fully functioning
person and what's that quote about like
uh humans are easy to uh to fool and you
you yourself are the one that's the
easiest the fact that you must inform
yourself yeah Richard Feynman yeah okay
so I came up I came up I thought I came
up with one and then you called me out
on Twitter twice with two different
ideas that were my idea that had already
existed but I'm gonna give you all three
and we can with the audience can vote on
whether or not mine's the coolest I'm
pretty sure it is so I called mine
vestigial pattern bias the successful
deliberate approaches we learned during
our development can become a prison
which stop us from being more
free-flowing and at ease when we are
developed the tools that got you from
naught to 50 are not the same ones that
get you from 50 to 90 or 90 to 95 but we
found success with this approach in the
past so we cling on to an overly
rational effortful approach we hope that
applying pure cerebral horsepower to a
situation will fix it we think think
that the more deliberate we are the
better the outcomes will be without
realizing that our subconscious is
aggregated to thousands of hours of
experience we've clocked up to now and
not using that experience is keeping us
in the same league that we've always
been in and you told me that the
einstelling effect the einstalling
effect occurs when pre-existing
knowledge impedes one's ability to reach
an optimal solution we become unable to
consider other Solutions when we think
we already have one even though it may
not be accurate or optimal it leaves us
cognitively incapable of differentiating
previous experience with current
problems so we may solve a problem but
we don't actually innovate and the final
One path dependence the QWERTY keyboard
layout was a misguided attempt to stop
typewriters jamming but despite it being
inefficient for typing it remains with
us because people accepted it as the
norm we failed to notice so many
problems because we let them become part
of life I think vestigial pattern bias
is by far the best named of the three
but I do
they're all part of the all part of the
same yeah I think that they're kind of
I would say that path dependence is is
the vestigial pattern bias in a social
setting so it's how it occurs at scale
um when everybody is thinking that way
when everybody is thinking with that
vestigial patent bias then you get the
result is you get path dependence
um I think that the einstall effect and
the
and the vestigial pattern bias are
pretty much the same thing I mean there
probably are subtle differences uh
between them but I think that the
general concept is the same which is
that our methods gradually rigidify
because we get used to solving problems
in a certain way and then that prevents
us from considering Alternatives
um and I think that this is something
that I've seen in my own life I I feel
like we tend to become blind to what
we're familiar with and this is you sent
me this uh great uh idea on on Twitter
actually DMS and I responded with um
with the whole frog frog and fish thing
which is that
um basically the frog says to the fish
how's the water
and the fish says what's water
and that's because the fish has lived
its whole life in water so it doesn't
know anything else I think it applies to
the vestigial pattern biasis which is
that we become so used to the solutions
that we uh use in our daily lives that
we just it just doesn't occur to us to
consider that we could do things a
different way
um I found this so many times with
regards to the ways that I write essays
for instance I've got a very standard
way of doing it and I've been using that
way for a very long time so much so that
I've almost forgotten that there are
other ways of doing it and it's only
been recently where I've been kind of
tinkering around and trying new things
that I've actually realized how sort of
how much I was constraining myself in my
methodology because
I just simply it just didn't occur to me
that I could do things a different way
I think this is probably responsible for
a lot of people's stagnation it's the
it's just this idea that people forget
that things can be changed and that's
why they don't change them I think
there's a good a good amount of scarcity
mindset that comes into this too that I
I have found a particular way of
wrangling reality into a form which
rewards me
oh I can't believe I've managed to do
this let's hold on let's grip it tighter
let's not let things change I learned
this when I did Rogan's show last year
and I sat down opposite this guy and
he's got it's a different sort of
episode to this right he's just the most
Meandering conversation like if he has a
bad stake the night before guess what
you're talking about steak for 20
minutes
he he sits down no notes in front of him
and just Jamie's already pressed the
button and then he just begins and you
watch this man hold a cogent
conversation together with no plan
Beyond what's front of mind and a bit of
prep that he's done for like three four
hours and it's it really opened up to me
as
the the importance of
um storytelling the importance of
allowing the Meander to happen uh the
importance of Leaning into it just being
a hang uh I've said for a long time that
the job of a podcaster is to be a Vibe
architect rather than a a blinkist for
podcasts that you're not trying to index
everything that's in someone's mind
you're trying to just create a vibe that
the audience can enjoy and you know the
vibe from from this episode might be
there are amazing ideas out there that
you don't know about and we're going to
Riff on them and you're going to learn
some and maybe you take them home with
you I've got one of the guys that's a
part of the sound of Freedom coming in
like the vibe from that is that there
are seriously evil people out there and
it is important that we're aware of it
and we need to protect children and
there's another vibe from this and
another vibe from that but within that
broader sort of landscape you can just
weave however you want and and that that
was really really interesting and that
again was you know my pattern bias was
showing that I have my way of preparing
I have my way of creating a show and
then I watch oh and I've listened to him
do it where he is he's like one of those
guys that's gone beyond the rule set you
know it's like once you reach seventh
Dan seventh degree black belt that you
have learned the rules so well that you
can then break them and you know that's
that's very very interesting and
obviously then opens up a huge more
ranges of learning because you're no
longer constrained by just the one or
two or three ways that you do things all
of the different paths are open to you
yeah absolutely I think for you this is
actually a great way to avoid the
vestigial pad bias because you meet so
many different people who have got
completely different ways of looking at
the world and different ways of doing
things so you're constantly being
exposed to new ideas I think it's
probably one of the greatest ways to
avoid vestigial advice would be to have
the kind of podcast that you have where
like you said you know one minute you're
talking about ideas the next minute
you're talking about you know crazy
evil people or whatever you know so it's
constantly mixing things up I think is
is the cure to this and I think
one of the problems is um that we
like the algorithmic sort of structure
of the internet
compels us to do things the same way
that we've always done them
um so for instance recommendation
algorithms or you know if you watch one
video of say Ben Shapiro
YouTube's just gonna just flood you with
Ben Shapiro videos you know and then now
you're watching even more of them and
then the more you watch of them you get
even more flooded with them and so it it
basically Narrows your sort of your
probability space of the things that you
could possibly learn and and uh you know
kind of the kinds of things that you
could uh the kinds of information you
could consume so
I think it is important
for no other if for no other reason than
to Simply uh keep your probability space
as wide as possible
to
do things against your own nature
to sort of have an anti-algorithm
to basically you know do things that
second guess yourself if you feel like
visiting a certain website visits a
completely different website you know
and and just do things try to second
guess yourself and to not have a fixed
routine one of the things that I do
sorry yeah one of the things that I do
now is that
um if I read uh from say like a
left-wing news source say like uh if I
read the New York Times then the
following day I will read right wing
news so I will read like The Wall Street
Journal uh you know so I'm constantly
shifting between different narratives
and that allows me to not be sort of
encapsulated and not be imprisoned
within one single narrative so that I'm
constantly being exposed to different
ways of looking at the world constantly
being exposed to new ways of of sort of
being as it were it would be awesome it
would be awesome if there was an app
that was able to do that for you I think
there is yeah I've forgotten the name of
it but there is actually a new AI app
which I was looking at recently
unfortunately in fact I might have it as
a bookmark but um yeah this is there's a
app which basically will give you
um different sort of information almost
at random basically based on
um but over time over over the space of
whatever two months you will end up with
an even split of Center left and right
yeah basically it gives you a wide range
yeah skeptical and and Pro-Tech and all
that stuff okay next one oppression
Olympics social media is a war for
public sympathy so victimhood is a
status symbol that many compete for by
collecting injuries real and imagined
often goading others into attacking them
so they can screenshot or record and
immortalize their prestigious oppression
I mean
so because we're living in an attention
economy
attention is
like money it's essentially currency you
know if you if you could get eyeballs
then that gives you power
and
one of the ways that people get
attention now is by trying to make
people empathic empathetic towards them
uh or sympathetic or whatever like they
they try to get people's emotions
engaged
into what their their life is and so
um you know if you could do that if you
can engage somebody's sympathies then
you can get them to do pretty much
anything you want them to do you can get
them to send you money you can get them
to boost your content to other people
you can get them to
um to give you some emotional support so
there are many ways that you can you can
sort of uh in a sense monetize people's
affection and
the easiest way to do it the simplest
way to do it is to
essentially pretend that you're
oppressed uh there's even a word for
this now uh it's known as sad fishing
which is when people go on social media
and they basically pretend that they're
oppressed not oppressed but they just
pretend that they're unfortunate they
pretend that something bad has happened
to them so it might not be oppression it
might it might be that they they might
pretend that they have uh mental illness
they might pretend that they're
depressed they might pretend that
they're their partner left them do you
remember the uh Trend last year or the
year before on Tick Tock where loads of
people were pretending they had multiple
personality disorder yes yes I actually
I wrote about this uh quite recently and
so this is something that is crazy I
mean this is like if you go on Tick Tock
and you type in did dissociative
identity disorder you will get just
video upon video upon video get millions
and millions of videos of people
claiming to have dissociative identity
disorder and by the way the substitute
identity disorder is multiple
personality disorder it's just the newer
newer name for it but um yeah there's
there's so many of these videos online
now like you'll just see
um people who will
shift between these personalities on on
a stream right uh just do it and they'll
pretend that they're like some first
they'll pretend that they're like a
six-year-old schoolgirl in Minnesota and
then they'll pretend that they're like
some um tribal Elder in Nairobi what's
it called is it others is it my other is
that's it [__] others yeah yeah and
so and and they basically um
the truth about did is quite very
interesting actually because there was a
guy recently unfortunately he died
um Ian hacking he's a philosopher and he
studied the spread of did uh back then
it was called multiple personality
disorder
um in the 1970s and what he found was
that in 1970 there were almost no cases
of multiple personality disorder it was
basically it was pretty much unheard of
um there was maybe one case or two cases
in the entire medical literature and
then what happened was that there was an
article written I think um I can't
remember which paper it was but it was a
pretty big paper about about this issue
about people having multiple uh
personality and it was it was more of a
speculative
um essay it was it was it wasn't really
you know medical kind of thing it was
more just somebody speculating about it
and then this kind of popularized this
idea and after this happened more and
more people began to claim that they had
uh multiple personalities and then what
happened is that the clinicians at the
time they were trying to work out why
this was happening because they didn't
really understand they didn't understand
social contagions at the time so they
were trying to work out why more people
were coming forward with uh multiple
personalities at the time they believed
that simply what was happening was that
just awareness of this condition was
increasing and so
they began speculating and they began
saying that
um people might be creating these
alternate Personalities in order to
repress memories of sexual abuse now we
now know that repressed memories are a
complete [__] they're not they're
not real repressed memories are Freudian
uh mumbo jumbo basically they're not
people don't repress memories based on
bad experiences it just doesn't happen
and there is something
um there is psychogenic amnesia but
that's that's different but but
repressed memories don't don't happen
and so uh we know for a fact that these
people were not they were not creating
these multiple personalities because
they've been sexually abused
um what was actually happening was that
they were looking at the diagnosis and
they were looking at reports of multiple
personality disorder and then they were
essentially using that to kind of make
sense of their own lives and so they
were creating these multiple
personalities in order to make sense of
their lives in a weird sort of way and
what Ian hacking found was that at the
beginning the average number of altars
that a person had was between two and
three and within in a decade the average
number was apparently 17. apparently
this is according to his work so I don't
know if this could be verified but this
is what Ian hacking found anyway in his
research and so I believe that did is
not a real disorder I don't believe it's
actually a real thing I believe it's a
complete fabrication and people who have
the idea are pretending because I've
actually looked at the medical
literature and there's only one one
study that I found which which in which
I think that there is actually a real
thing going on in which people actually
do have multiple personalities and
that's a thing called um psychological
gating
it's a very very bizarre study I'm not
really sure what to make of it but what
I found with this one study and this is
the only study that's convinced me that
maybe there are people out there who
have multiple personalities is that
there's a woman who actually presented
to a clinic with blindness and she
actually she was blind
and apparently she also had another
altar living within her and apparently
the altar within her was not blind
and apparently what the uh the
experimenter found was that when this
woman shifted there was actually a shift
in the activity in her optic nerve
so something strange was going on that
when she shifted
to a different state of mind when she
shifted it to another altar suddenly she
could see a blind woman could see so
that kind of creeped me out I don't know
how much to believe this because this
hasn't been replicated and I'm very wary
about these kinds of studies psychology
is a bit a bit Shady you can't really
trust a single study because there's so
many you know so many of these are just
made up a lot of these psychological
studies are made up so I don't know
whether to trust it if it's true then
maybe I can be convinced that multiple
personalities maybe are a thing but I
have so far seen no evidence that
multiple personalities are actual thing
other than what people pretend and this
is why it's crazy when you look at Tick
Tock and you see all these videos of
people pretending that they've got
multiple personalities and the reason
that they're doing it is obviously
because it brings them attention
sympathy yeah it's the oppression
Olympics if you have a mental like this
is another thing like previously people
the main way that people were oppressed
was through sociological systems so it
would be the patriarchy that was
oppressing you would be systemic racism
or it would be capitalism but now
there's a new way of being oppressed
which is through
psychology and through medicine or
rather not medicine but through biology
and um
a lot of people I've seen are now doing
this they're pretending to have
conditions that they don't have and
we've seen it with Tourette's um there's
a there's a famous tick tocker called
ticks and Roses who was uh caught uh
fabricating her Tourette's basically for
the cloud because she wanted people to
like her you know she she wanted clout
online and so she she pretended to have
these ticks and people thought the ticks
were really strange because they weren't
they weren't like normal ticks and they
seemed to occur only when she was you
know only when she had a camera when she
knew that she had a camera on her
because when she didn't know that she
had a camera on her suddenly the ticks
went away
um and there was another there was a guy
who was a twitch streamer
um I've forgotten his name but he was
quite a famous twitch streamer and he
pretended that he couldn't walk and then
there was a there was a stream [__]
video of him yeah I've seen this video
yeah yeah
so this is this is a common thing people
pretending that they've got illnesses
that they don't have and I've written an
entire article about it a long like 4
000 word about it um in which you know I
just document like why people are doing
this and yeah can people get this if
they want to read the articles so this
is on my sub stack so it's just
goinda.substack.com and the article is
called the pathologization pandemic
which is my name for this phenomenon
um so you know it's so I originally um
actually I won't go into it too much
because I let people read it but I'll
focus on what I was talking about before
which is basically the whole Tick-Tock
thing which is
um you know people
on Tick Tock are doing this at crazy
rates there's just the number of cases
of people
um pretending to have these conditions
on Tick Tock surpasses the number of
cases in real life you know so so so
there are more people with multiple
personality disorder on Tick Tock than
there are in real life and it obviously
you know this just goes to show that
these people are just completely making
it up and
it is obviously because people want
sympathy and I I don't hold it against
these people I don't I don't do them as
bad people I think that they're just
doing what the market is demanding that
they do these people want attention and
they they want they want to be loved
like every other human being wants to be
loved and they want um they want a clout
this is why this is this is why your
article on audience capture I think
twins with this pathologization pandemic
thing so nicely because it the audience
cap Perils of audience capture explains
the incentives and explains how you have
this sort of self-reinforcing recursive
feedback loop between Creator and
audience and Creator and audience
um I remember I read in a book once I
think it's Steve Stuart Williams who
says uh sympathy is investment advice so
that when we feel sympathy it is
advising us of the person who is so
lowly that if we give them our effort it
will be rewarded and they will be
grateful for it so much higher than
somebody who wasn't as desperate and
down than the look and so to speak which
is why sympathy you know you start
[__] pulling that trigger and it's
it's why you know these golden retriever
or like rescue dog
um reels on Instagram do like really I
saw this one the other day that had
seven million likes I've never seen a
reel with seven million likes before and
uh it was some dog and this dog's been
it was hurt and it was trying to bite
the people that were getting it and it
was all scraggly and then they wash it
and they they feed it and they give it
antibiotics and they bring it back and
here it is with its owners jumping
around in the yard and you're like in 60
seconds I've got like the an amazing
story of this dog and I feel sympathy
toward it and now I'm all happy and I'm
[__] weeping and I'm like I'm
watching the video of a dog why am I
weeping so
sympathy is just such a it's such a
compelling
engagement a reason to engage yeah it's
such it's so magnetic uh yes yeah it's
it's I mean it is the thing that will
get people likes and retweets online you
know um you see
you can see this with with Twitter for
instance you see that people who don't
really
um
evoke sympathy in their audiences can
have a massive follow account but they
won't get very many likes on their
tweets whereas somebody who really
sort of forms a connection with their
audience they can have far fewer
followers but they'll get so much more
likes because their audience is engaged
and they're like they're actually
invested in this person's life and they
actually want to know the way I look at
it is it's almost like a movie character
like what like the structure of a movie
is that the first sort of half an hour
of a film like the act one of a movie is
designed to get you to like the
character then get to like the main
character why should I so you you do it
yeah develop this sympathy exactly and
um once you've developed the sympathy
for the character then you want to watch
more of that character you want to see
what happens to them and then you're
rooting for that character and you're
invested in that character and the same
thing happens with social media where
people will try to create this struggle
that they're having one of the ways that
screenwriters will make a character
um beloved to an audience is that they
will give them a struggle they'll make
life hard for them so if somebody has a
struggle then you can you can identify
with that person because everybody has a
struggle in their life and if that
struggle is a universal struggle so if
it's like a guy that wants to get a girl
for instance or you know somebody who
wants overcoming poverty or whatever or
overcoming poverty or you know all of
that kind of stuff these are Universal
struggles they're like me yeah exactly
it is me yeah and so if you can make you
know if you can convince people that
this person has got this struggle in
their life which you can identify with
then that will make you love that person
so much more because you'll begin to see
yourself in that person and you'll root
for them and you'll wanna you wanna you
want them to have a happy ending and I
think this happens with social media as
well yeah let me give you an input there
so I learned this from baggage claim uh
Manisha and the critical Drinker as well
uh both um online YouTube film critics I
suppose and um Manisha is very
um anti this sort of new wave of female
boss boss [__] Heroes that are kind of
being portrayed online that um if you
look at the difference between the two
Mulan films in the first one she had to
be uh Innovative and crafty because she
was smaller than the rest of them and in
the second one she was better than all
of the men immediately because she had
like estrogen she or something like that
or in in the second doctor strange
there's like a the daughter the the
Central American daughter of a lesbian
couple has the most power in the entire
universe and the only reason that she
can't use it is because she doesn't
believe in herself because like like
yeah yeah
I've seen them some critical drinkers uh
videos and there's one where he's
commenting about Star Wars and about how
Rey is basically a Mary Sue uh the main
character ring what's a Mary too
so a Mary Sue is like a character who is
basically like a kind of like a a
Fantasy character it's like basically
the author injecting themselves as as an
ideal figure in in the movie so there'll
be somebody who's just basically good at
everything and who is perfect in every
way you know somebody who never ever has
any sort of setbacks or if they do have
a setback they'll immediately overcome
it there's there's never any struggle
with this character so they're basically
just perfect and um a lot of people have
accused Ray of being this this kind of
character I've not actually seen the
newest Star Wars movies but because I
don't really have any interest in it but
I I but the the conversation about this
is so wide that even I know who Rey is
even though I've never watched the movie
so Rey is the main character of the
newer Star Wars movies of the new
Trilogy and um she's basically I think
she's related to Luke Skyward I don't
know but anyway she's the main character
and um
she is basically instantly good at
everything you know she she doesn't need
to be trained by a Jedi master like I've
seen the original Star Wars movies and
Luke Skywalker he had to be trained by
Yoda and by Obi-Wan Kenobi in order to
become the great Jedi that he would
become but apparently I haven't seen
this new these new movies so I might get
this wrong but I've heard from I think
critical Drinker and others that
basically Ray doesn't need to learn
anything she just has the abilities
already she has the Jedi Powers she
knows how to wield a lightsaber from the
get-go she has everything already you
know and it's like basically like I
think he basically attributes it to this
new wave of like hyper feminism in
Hollywood where you know the female
characters are always more competent in
the male characters and it's patronizing
that it's I I understand we need to come
up with a name for this so have a little
bit of a think about this if you
optimize for being
let's say sympathetic or empathetic or
caring or comforting on the front end
without considering the second third
fourth order effects down the line and
how that might be adverse to the group
that you are supposedly trying to help
so for instance if you think about an
entire generation of girls now who are
growing up with these kinds of female
leads
yes maybe the initial experience is them
being told girls are great if you're
female you can achieve whatever you want
blah blah blah right the second third
fourth order effects of this are if you
all of the heroes never had to encounter
a difficulty so when you do in your life
who are the role models that you look up
to any difficulty that you do encounter
in your life is due to something
structural and you should complain about
the world as opposed to change yourself
or adapt to it or accept the fact that
sometimes life can be shitty like it
makes a according to Manisha baggage
claim it makes an entire generation a
fragile narcissists women and yeah you
know she uses
um
who's [__] Prince Harry's wife
Meghan Markle Meghan Markle she is on
like a vendetta against Meghan Markle
but she sees Meghan Markle as kind of
like the poster child for this
vulnerable narcissistic uh kind of um
like yeah position and uh yeah I I think
that I think it's right I think that
um not teaching women especially that
they are not only worthy but capable of
overcoming difficult things because it's
somehow more inspirational to never show
a woman facing any ad uh like
adversarial situations to me just seems
like it's it's stupid so exactly yeah
yeah I I think that one of the reasons
why people watch movies is so that they
can actually understand
um how to overcome difficulties like
what kind of a character must they be in
order to overcome some of the sort of
obstacles in life you know if it's one
of the obviously not the only reason but
I think it's one of them and I think it
does serve a good purpose in that way
because it gives us ideals to Aspire to
it gives this
um you know sort of people that we can
model our own lives on
um but the problem is is that if this
person is is unrealistic if they're if
they're too ideal then it can be
dangerous to try to model your life on
them because the the
the kinds of things that they would
deserve in navarre's sense of the term
are not gonna
equate they're not going to translate to
reality so if somebody so for example
like um this Ray character
if she can instantly overcome everything
uh she you know like some guy attacks
her and then she's instantly just you
know whips his ass
um that's not going to translate to the
real world because
the sad fact is is that for you know men
are
on average a lot stronger than women so
if a woman were to emulate Rey in the
real world and you know she's trying to
physically take down a guy the chances
are she's gonna get beaten down you know
so it's just not going to work like what
works in a movie is not going to work in
reality and I think this is one of the
dangerous things about
trying to click turn these kinds of
people into Role Models because that's
what they're trying to do they're trying
to turn Ray into a role model for women
you know and another thing is is that
why would why would you make
a role model
um just defeat every problem with
physical violence because I think that's
what she does she just uses the force
she just knocks people over and kills
them with a sword or whatever you know
this is not a role model for for any
human being like you know it's just what
what exactly are you supposed to learn
from this that you could just kick
everybody's ass is that the lesson
you're supposed to learn it's not it
doesn't teach anybody anything it's just
it's a fantasy and so when they when a
lot of these writers because you watch
these documentaries of how they made the
movie and a lot of them will sort of you
know stroke their chins and say yes but
we wanted to create a modern woman you
know like somebody who the Modern Woman
could relate to and all this sort of
stuff but modern women can't relate to
that kind of literally the least
relatable woman exactly that's what yeah
that's it and that's what Mary Sue is
and Mary Sue is somebody who's just so
good at everything that they're just not
relatable in any sense of the term that
you just can't you know they're
superhuman and that's why out of all the
superheroes my least favorite is
Superman a lot of people might might
disagree me on that but I don't like
Superman because he's just good at
everything he's just he's a god
basically he's got there is his only
weakness is this mythical substance that
doesn't even exist in the real world but
Kryptonite you know so it's just like
the floors I like I like characters
who've got flaws you know unlike Batman
because he's got flaws he's you know
he's he's a kind of rich guy and all
this sort of stuff but he's got his dark
side as well and he's he's constantly
trying to fight with his his own
craziness his own dark so he's an
outcast you know so there's you've got
to have flaws I think in a character if
you if you want to make them appealing
to to other human beings uh which is I
don't you know I just don't get why they
make so many Mary series they should
have learned this by now but let's do
two more so uh we'll do mine first we'll
do mine first and we'll finish on one of
yours so this is productivity purgatory
the ancient Greek word for work was not
at leisure a 21st century grind
addiction has turned Pursuits like walks
in nature meditation and time and
sunlight into just another productivity
hack slowly turning all leisure
activities into a tribute to work
yeah so I've been thinking about this
for a long time
um so basically there's Greek uh sort of
classification of tasks so ancient Greek
classification of tasks uh they they
divided tasks into tele activities and
antenna activities now telek comes from
the Greek word Telos which means an end
or a gold
and telec activities are activities that
you do in order to reach some goal so an
example of this would be washing the
dishes or um you know washing your car
or doing some kind of chore or job you
know going to a job to do your work
and then opposed to this is atelect
activities and atelect activities are
activities that you do for the sake of
the activity itself and not for any
other goal so an example of this would
be
um
anything that you enjoy so painting
maybe a picture if you enjoy doing that
you know I mean that could be both uh
telek because you're doing it for the
love of painting but you're also doing
it to have a painting at the end of it
so that maybe that's not a good example
so I would say um a tele a good example
of an atelic activity would be going for
a walk in the park or something you know
assuming you're not doing it for
exercise but you're just doing it just
headache well you could do it for
exercise but you're not doing it to
reach a certain destination you're just
doing it to
for the sake of walking you know you're
walking for the sake of walking
and what I've been trying to do in my
life is I'm trying to turn a lot of my
telek activities into a tele activities
I've got these I've got this I think the
correct terminology for you here uh
autotelic derives goals joy and reward
mostly internally judging their own
actions exotelic derives goals joined
reward externally takes care how their
actions are being judged yeah I mean I
use the words helic and atelic um
maybe I think they're a bit simpler yeah
t e l i c yeah and yeah so it's called
telicity
um that's the terms those are the terms
that I use yeah oh well this has been
hijacked by a bunch of like athleisure
companies so it's taking me all I can
see a lime green uh like slip-on [__]
uh no no I think the best thing to do is
I'll just type in t t e l i c I did I
did and it came up with a bunch of
sandals and it will I'll I'll check it
out afterwards so telekinetalic cool
yeah yeah so so I'm trying to turn
um sort of my tele activities into
atelect ones I'm trying to do more
things just for the sake of doing them
because I think if you can enjoy the
activity itself and not think too much
about the goal uh then you will become
much more you'll become more content
with your life I think I think a lot of
people do things just for some kind of
goal and they don't enjoy the process of
doing the thing that they're trying to
do have you got it as a result of that
they become less they'll become less
good at actually achieving the goal yeah
have you got any eye advice on how you
are becoming more italic
yeah so I try to find enjoyable ways of
doing things because there are there
usually are there are less enjoyable
ways to do it these are more enjoyable
ways of doing things so for example
um I used to hate working out but I've
started working out recently and the way
I've I've made it into more of an
enjoyable activity is that I I listened
to music that I really really enjoy but
I only allow myself to listen to that
music when I'm working out so if I want
a hero tune that I really really enjoy I
can only listen to it if I'm working out
so that compels me to work out so it
makes the process of working out more
enjoyable because I'm focusing on the
music and you know I'm just kind of like
uh just doing that so little things like
that you can just turn activities into
um into more enjoyable things and also
another thing is when I go for walks for
instance I used to kind of find Walking
boring because I would go through the
same group all this all the time but now
I mix up my roots and I've go down
streets that I've never gone down before
yeah I love getting parks and yeah and
just completely just losing myself
because I'm living in a new area now so
all of this is alien to me the area that
I'm in now so I just basically just
wonder I just choose a direction and I
just go in that direction and then I
just end up at these unexpected places
and I might see some like crazy Cafe in
the middle of corner somewhere and just
that looks nice and just go in there so
you just make a simple thing like
walking far more enjoyable by adding
that element of surprise and the
suspense you know so going back to what
you were saying about how you create
that suspense for your audience yeah I
think suspense can really help make
things a lot more enjoyable when you
when things are a little bit
unpredictable when you don't know how
they're going to turn out I think
unpredictability is one of the great
spices of life if you can make something
unpredictable then it becomes a lot more
exciting and a lot more enjoyable and
you don't need to take huge risks with
this unpredictability sounds like uh you
know I'm gonna try and make it home on
half a tank of gas even though I've got
200 miles to go or I'm gonna have to
jump out of an airplane or something
like that unpredictability can be as
benign as you want it to be it can be
you know taking a left instead of a
right on the way to work yeah okay final
one for today we got so many that we
didn't get through uh presentism we
judge history by modern standards we
regard slave owners as evil but slavery
was so common and familiar to our
forebearers that they were blind to its
iniquities as a Wii to the industrial
Slaughter of animals for which we too
will eventually be called evil
yeah so I'm I'm one of those people who
gets upset when I hear about the way
animals are treated in sort of you know
factory farms
um I just think that the way that
they're treated is absolutely horrific
and if if it was something that we had
no knowledge of but that just suddenly
was revealed to us today
I think there would be a massive
movement against it to end it because of
the ways that they're treated I mean
pigs for instance pigs apparently
according to some studies are they have
similar levels of intelligence to a
seven-year-old child
um and that they know when they're being
they're going to be killed and you know
they'll resist it as much as they can
and yet you know you hear stories of
them being buried alive
um by by Farmers because they you know
they might have not even that they
actually have foot and mouth disease but
there's a chance that they might catch
it and because of that large numbers of
them are buried alive and just that's
just one example I mean the treat in a
horrific ways in in factory farms and
I I think I'm I'm quite sort of
surprised that people don't view this is
more horrific than it actually than it
actually is because we care about dogs
we care about dogs a lot you know we
wouldn't want to see dogs treated like
this and yet pigs are a lot smarter than
dogs they're a lot more self-aware than
dogs and yet we we treat them in the
most barbaric ways and I think that
what's holding people back a lot of time
is a people are just used to it and this
goes this is like the opposite of
hedonic adaptation where there's a kind
of like nightmare adaptation where you
know if something's horrific but we're
just used to it it's just a suffering
adaptation yeah yeah it's no it's no
longer horrific because we're just used
to it and so we're born into this world
in which animals are treated in these
barbaric ways so we don't really kick up
a fuss about it and we just focus on the
beautiful Taste of a steak or whatever
and that's enough for us you know this
is weird it's this weird sort of um
cognitive dissonance in the mind to what
I've observed amongst some people I saw
this one thing once which was crazy
where I saw somebody
um
who was watching a a video on their
phone while they were in a McDonald's
and they were they were they were
watching a a video of a uh like a cow of
a a cow and they had a Big Mac on the
desk next to him they were eating their
Big Mac while they were looking at this
cute cow on YouTube and going oh and ah
over it you know it's this weird split
brain thing goes on in people's brains
and everybody does this you know you see
a cow you'll be like oh that's so cute
you know it's it's lovely you know
listen you want to stroke it and all
that but then you can just go to
McDonald's and pick up a Big Mac and
you'll be eating probably it's cousin or
something you know so it's like um this
weird sort of cognitive distance that we
have in our brains and I think that
that's only going to be remedied when we
no longer uh need to kill animals in
order to have food in order to have meat
um it's not that we need meat now we can
survive without meat although it's not
it's not quite as efficient but
um I think like if we you know if we
could
when the time comes when we can actually
create burgers in a lap and those
Burgers taste just as good as natural
Burgers then I think people will
actually have more of a motivation to
end
um suffering and the reason why I think
is because we have the president which
is that the Industrial Revolution made
slavery less necessary in order to
maintain the economy
um before the Industrial Revolution
slavery was kind of needed to maintain
the economy and so people did they
turned a blind into how horrifically
evil it is but it wants the Industrial
Revolution came about and the Machinery
became available to do the slaves work
then people suddenly realized oh we
don't need this anymore now we can we
have the luxury of being ethical
so ethics is to a certain extent a
product of luxury
um if you look at how history was it was
often that way it was often brutal
because it had to be brutal in a way and
this is something that a lot of people
don't like to hear but it's the truth
history had to be brutal because there
was no alternative at that time and now
that we have the luxury of not having to
be so brutal looking back at history and
seeing how brutal people were makes us
recoil in horror how we were but those
people who engaged in these barbaric
acts they were not any more evil than us
they just were living in a in a world
that required that kind of brutality
unfortunately what's the broader lesson
from presentism then so I would say that
we need to be careful not to judge
people too much and I'm not saying that
we should go all moral relativists or
anything but we need to take into
account what people can do in their
lives like for instance
um if you look at the Ukraine war the
Ukraine war is absolutely brutal you
know there's cluster bombs are now being
sold and you know there's a lot of very
horrific Munitions which cause
widespread damage are being used
um unfortunately you know it's it's easy
to say this is barbarican's evil and
it's it's horrible but you've got to
look at what what actually are there
Alternatives they have to fight with
everything they've got because if they
don't they're going to die they're going
to get killed and so they have to be as
brutal as they can possibly be
and this is something that a lot of
people don't seem to understand it's
that you know even the most horrific
people and I I don't want to defend
people like Assad but I remember that
during the Syrian War
um Assad was basically being criticized
for using um chemical weapons and
obviously chemical weapons are
absolutely horrific and they're nasty
but
he was using those weapons because he
didn't have uh Precision guided bombs he
didn't have the technology that the West
has the West can afford to be more
Humane in its bombing campaigns because
it's got Precision guided Weaponry so it
can afford to just Target you know it
can actually Target just the the enemy
combatants it doesn't need to have
civilian casualties but even it does
have civilian casualties but it can
minimize them somebody like Assad who
doesn't have that kind of Technology but
who feels in his what he needs to
protect his family he needs to win his
war from his point of view like I said I
don't agree with Assad I don't I think
he's horrible human being but from his
point of view he needs to win that war
so he's going to use what methods are
available to him to win that war and
that includes using chemical weapons
because chemical weapons are very
effective and they did prove effective
in the Syrian War they managed to clear
huge areas from enemy combatants and
they were able to kill people behind
cover in you know which is what normal
Munitions can't do but you know we need
to bear in mind that people are only
going to behave ethically when it's
within their capabilities to do so and
it's not always within their capability
to do so and people need to realize that
this is true of their own selves I think
if you eat meat you've got to reckon
with the fact that you are engaging in
something that is
sort of causing a huge amount of
suffering to sentient animals and you
know I say this is somebody who hasn't
eaten meat I try not to eat as much meat
as I as I do as I did
um I try to eat sort of more you know
lower sentience uh animals sort of stuff
like shelves all the time yeah yeah I
try to eat that a bit more than eating
the higher ordered animals but you know
even I can't resist a good State now and
again but I'm I try not to because even
when I do eat steaks I eat sort of
animals that have been able to roam the
fields and stuff you know I don't eat
factory farmed stuff but that's a luxury
that's a luxury that I have because I
can afford to buy food that's organic
um that has you know been allowed to
roam free I if I was poor I would have
to eat factory farmed animals so I
wouldn't judge that person I'm not going
to judge somebody because they're
they're too poor to eat organic food you
know or you know um that food that has
welfare standards I'm not going to judge
them because they don't have that
capability so I think we do need to take
into account
um I think that's what Chris presentism
gives us it gives us the idea that we
need to consider the context in which
people are unethical because do they
actually have the alternative do they
have the ability to do otherwise
and if they don't then we we need to
maybe
you know not not be so harsh but I do
think I do think people have the ability
to not be so evil to animals now so I do
judge people
um I judge everybody including myself
for eating me because I think we're
getting to the point now where it's no
longer necessary to eat meat we can have
uh food that's been grown in a lab and
you know I think that if you don't do
that then
you're essentially quite unethical
because you're you're choosing the
suffering of an animal
over the non-suffering of an animal I
learned this from Alex O'Connor
five years ago I think maybe four or
five years ago and he'd managed to
convince me someone that's been a
lifelong me teacher and still is that if
I do choose to continue to eat meat
which I have done uh that I need to
reckon with the fact that I'm causing
suffering and that you know if I was
being
fully ethically aligned with my beliefs
and my actions that I probably would
stop eating meat I would certainly at
least reduce it down as much as well
this is it strikes me as kind of like
path dependence
um you know all the vestigial pattern
bias this is essentially a kind of
instance of that we eat meat today
because we've always eaten meat and we
don't think about it because we've never
thought about it but if it was something
that we'd never eaten in our lives if we
had gone our whole lives being vegan not
knowing the concept of eating other
animals then suddenly if a steak was
presented in front of us and we were
told that this is another living being
that that's been slaughtered so that we
can eat it I think that would absolutely
horrify us so we do it because we've
always done it and it's that's why these
old habits die hard and I think it will
take time for us to adjust to eating lab
growing I mean obviously there's all
these conspiracy theories now about how
lab-grown meat is is going to be pumped
full of chemicals that will either
sterilize this to reduce the population
for or whatever or you know there's
going to be all kinds of stuff about
that but I mean um you know I'll be I
for one would be happy to not have
animals suffer anymore in the way that
they've been suffered on a scale of
hundreds of billions of you yeah over
the years so yeah going to Bogle ladies
and gentlemen dude I absolutely adore
speaking to you every time we do these
episodes I leave feeling fired up and
and ready to go learn more stuff about
the world where should people go if they
want to keep up to date with all of the
[__] that you're doing yeah so the best
thing to do is to just find me on
Twitter
um probably the best thing to do is just
type goinda Twitter into Google that's
the easiest way to do it uh or sub stack
again you can just type in gowinda sub
stack and uh that's where the main
places that I'll be found and uh then
yeah I might try some other new things
soon but I'm not ready to announce them
quite yet that's all right dude when you
are we will run this back soon enough I
appreciate the hell out of you thank you
for today yeah thanks Chris it's always
a pleasure to be here if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe